- There are four essential
things if you want to win on
the internet in 2021.
let's get into it.
Everybody is so obsessed with,
is this gonna be around?
- Yeah.
I don't care if its gonna be around.
- (indistinct)
- Right now
- Yeah.
- Is the radio station gonna be around?
Yes? No? Who gives a fuck?
Tell me where everybody's attention is?
- Yeah.
- The streets.
- Where it's underpriced.
Listen I want a TV show--
- Wait, hang on.
- Go ahead.
- Let me clarify to these people.
- Please.
- When you say underpriced
you just talking about--
- Attention.
- Up and coming.
Oh, okay got you.
- So attention.
Where's underpriced...
What I call underpriced attention.
Instagram influencers.
If you take all 300 million Americans
and you ask them to
sell this bottled water,
and they had unlimited budget
everybody had a million dollars,
How would they sell it?
I believe that 90% of Americans
would make a TV commercial.
- Hmm.
- Or do a billboard.
- When that's some bullshit.
- Correct?
- Yeah (indistinct)
- What I would do with my money,
is I would give it to a bunch
of influencers on Instagram
and I would make one or two
great videos for Facebook,
three minutes long,
and that's what I would do.
- And that's exactly what
these big corporations is doing
like Nike,
even with the Adidas with me,
grabbing me to do a sneakers,
they grabbing these influencers or--
- Correct.'cause Ferg
- Socialites.
- 'Cause you know what it
is, you're underpriced.
- Hmm, and they can get you.(finger snaps)
- Of course, because just
like me, my book, my book,
sells a hundred thousand copies in a week.
I'm making them money.
They give me a $3 million advance,
I'm happy.
- Right.
- 'cause I'm using them as a bank.
- You're using Adidas as a bank.
- Right.
- You get me an advance upfront--
- Yeah.
- But they, but, but
- Its like the label.
I'm just gonna label as a bank.
- That's all it is.
That's all it is.
That's all by the way--
- I'm using y'all as a bank,
(man laughs)
- that's all it is.
That all, that's all it is.
So what I do, is I care only about them.
I only care--
- I love y'all.
- about Miranda.
I only care about King David.
I only care about Nicholas.
I only care about Bala.
I only care about them.
'Cause they're the only ones
- You specialize to them
- that matter.
- Right.
- Cause they're the attention arbitrage.
- [Man] Right.
- And that's why I give them so much love
and that's why I give all
of my business advice away
for free,
because I wanna be more valuable
to them,
- [Asap] Right.
than they are to me.
- So underpriced attention to me is,
things like the super bowl
in America cost $6 million,
and I think it's unbelievably underpriced.
Because a hundred million people
will watch your commercial.
Meanwhile, I think a regular
commercial on the telly
is overpriced.
Because there's assumptions about GRPs
and Nielsen ratings that
I just know are not true
in common sense.
Facebook Organic used to be the
greatest thing in the world,
it doesn't even exist anymore.
It's an ad product.
Running the ads on Facebook as we do
and we took tune of hundreds
of millions of dollars,
there's a lot of ways
to make it underpriced.
It's by doing contextual creative at scale
and doing 80 different
media spends instead of one.
There's ways to make it overpriced
on LinkedIn, YouTube, Facebook,
where you just do one video
and you just try to
reach everybody 18 to 55.
So I spend my life,
being religious around
where is the nook and cranny
that allows me to pay 5 cents,
that is really worth 20 cents on business,
in a minefield where
there's a lot of places
you can spend 20 cents and
only get 5 cents value.
That's what I mean by
underpriced attention.
So for me one of the things
that really stands out
is if I was asking the normal
quote and quote person,
to produce a hundred
pieces of content a day,
I guarantee you that I'm
probably subconsciously thinking
that 50 of those are Twitter.
You can write, you can
retweet and add your 2 cents,
all of a sudden you're
kind of there, Right?
The other thing is,
I don't think people understand
document versus create.
I think people think you need Drock
or Jason following you,
Dustin following you around,
I think it's just taking a picture,
Like I see content right here.
Like I see content and I...
Maybe I have...
This is probably my strength.
I see content in everything.
I think you should take a
photo of us talking right now
and tweet it and be like,
"Holy shit I'm doing this
"with Gary Vee right now."
- [Man] Yeah.
- Like, Like, right?
- Yeah I did, I took one
before you came in.
- Okay (chuckles)
but like, there is Madison Square Garden.
- [Man] Yeah.
- And you know like,
like, this is New York.
I think there's a lot more content.
And by the way, I think that
could be done 15 to 20 times
on Twitter, Instagram stories and TikTok
without any cost to the
preciousness that is the main reason
that everybody can't make
a hundred pieces of content.
- [Man] Okay.
- You know taking a photo of what you see
and adding one sentence is
allowing people into your world
and you start creating
around common interests.
A lot of people are like,
"Gary, should I separate
my business and life?"
I'm like I put my jets
content in my, all my content.
I put my garage sales stuff there.
That has nothing to do with the marketing
or the business running.
I think it's there, but I do
think it's a strategy mindset,
and I think everybody
thinks this is useless
and nobody would care,
and I think you should let them decide.
You're in the content business.
Every fucking artist ever,
sucked until they put a banger out.
- [Man] Exactly.
- Everybody sucked
until they put out a song
that made them not suck.
Alanis Morissette, nobody knew, killed it.
You understand? It's as simple as that.
And now that you've
SoundCloud and fucking Spotify
and YouTube,
there's no more A&R and fucking
MTV and fuck the labels,
It's like no fucking excuses.
Get in studio, make a song, put it out,
DM a thousand influencers,
hope somebody shares it,
fucking then let the market decide.
I know everybody gets mad at me for saying
the same advice,
It's the right advice.
It's how you get into better shape--
- [listener] Yeah yeah.
- Exercise and eating right.
Sorry, Sorry that's what it is.
- So let's get straight in.
So tell me, let's, we're
talking about authenticity
in a brand--
- Yes.
- What does it mean to you
from a brand communication?
(Gary sighs)
- You know, this is the
interesting question.
I have a pretty,
for this world,
a pretty left field point of view on this.
And my point of view is that
we need to achieve relevance.
I'm looking at 11, 12, 13 faces right now
and what Pepsi or BMW or Coca-Cola
or Facebook means to all these
people is actually different.
And so for me authenticity
gets very close to relevancy
because when you're a big brand,
there are so many variables in your world.
There's so many things that you're doing.
Some people may drink a Cola
to get a burst of energy,
others it may be a
reminder of spending time
with their grandmother.
And I think we're so literal
in today's branded marketing world.
We're so stuck on sentences and adjectives
and we spend so much
time on subjective things
that don't matter to the
consumer on the other end.
So my perspective is
much like a human being
you and I are gonna act
differently right now as humans
in this interview,
than if we were with our family,
than if we were in a weekend in Las Vegas
with our best friends,
than if we were presenting
to 5,000 people.
People are always like, "Gary,
you're a little bit different
"than when you, I see you on video."
I'm like, " yeah, I'm
on stage to 7,000 people
"versus I'm here with you."
There's different versions.
And I think people struggle in ad land
to understand things
are multi-dimensional.
And so for me authenticity
is actually being comfortable
in the 74 to 7,400 variations
of how you show up.
And so I think that we are,
that human beings, executives,
are limiting brand's
ability to be authentic
because they want it to
be so literal and so safe.
And so PRd, and so
approved by the queen bee,
that I think we live in a
very non-authentic world.
And I think the reason
humans continue to scale
in popularity,
is they're a focus group of the audience,
they're an executive group of one.
I think one of the
reasons real celebrities
are struggling,
and have lost share is
they do have PR people.
They do have big deals with movie studios
that they're scared of breaking and so,
I think anyone who could actually show
all the versions of themselves will win,
and I think right now
the creative industry,
A isn't set up to make enough creative,
B has way too much B2B DNA in it
to actually show up authentic.
And this is not schizophrenia,
this is not throw up against
the wall and see what sticks,
this is not being scattered,
this is being true.
And so I think authenticity
has a far more,
at its end there's always
that something that delivers
at the end.
A piece of content or creative.
And I think it's being far more wide
than it's been over the last 80 years.
- The reason I have
that feeling towards you
as far as more of a friendship
even though we'd never,
never met before don't know each other
is authenticity.
You get, you see somebody on
social media and you're like,
"that's, that's a good dude right there."
- Well and you know, and
you and I got to hang out
at eight at 2021 and in mobile.
- [Gary] Yap.
- There is a level of humility
to you that you can sense
in person.
- Absolutely.
- Way more than you can on video.
- Yes. And it's almost, it almost more--
- I'm de, by the way I
apologize for interrupting.
- [Man in blue shirt] Yeah go on.
- I'm like desperate to meet everybody
'cause to your point,
and I'm sure you didn't sense that
when I was talking directly to you,
it's when you got to watch me--
- [Man in blue shirt] Yeah
- Work a room, in my natural state,
prep for going on stage.
I know that about me.
I know literally last night
I was telling my parents,
literally last night.
That the one thing that I'm...
I was telling them how
I don't like somebody.
Let me rephrase.
'Cause it's not the truth.
That I don't respect somebody
that is a very famous business person,
because they're just not nice.
- Hmm.
- And I was saying last night,
cause my dad was in the room,
we had an employee once
steal $700,000 worth of wine
from us,
and I said that I would
forgive that person tomorrow
if they called me and help them.
Which drives my dad crazy.
That was (indistinct).
(group laughs)
But I said, "but, if I saw
somebody be unkind to a cashier
"at burger King?
"It's a death blow.
"I can never have a real
relationship with them again."
- Mm.
- You know, I assume, I mean,
you can jump in here but
you got to see it when I
knew you weren't watching
which then leads to the truth.
- Well, you know, what it was for me was,
we had just got back from Cuba.
- [Gary] I remember.
- And you get pulled away,
right after we told you,
we got back from Cuba.
You talked to everybody in
the room and you come back.
"So tell me more about Cuba."
(group laughs)
It's like genuinely care, you know?
And it's almost,
I don't wanna say off-putting,
but it's, it's like,
'cause you're expecting bravado
and you know things like
that, but it's like,
wow, that's a really nice freaking dude.
- It's funny,
when social started happening,
I'm like, Oh this is gonna be good for me
because what I knew,
is I genuinely like people.
Like, for example,
when I came into this room,
I didn't say hello,
because I'm strategically
thinking when you leave,
you'll tell everybody
that Gary Vee is nice.
I said, hello 'cause
it's my natural being.
- [group Member] Hmm.
That's what Cuba was.
- [group Member] Yeah.
- It's exhausting to try to game it.
- [Group Member] Right.
- You can't game it.
I would highly recommend
you focus on sales.
You have to figure out
can you sell your thing?
Whatever that is.
It's a service, sell out the show,
your thing that you actually sell.
If you're not capable of selling
as a solopreneur there's really
nothing else that matters.
Because money intake
is the way you continue
to the next move, right?
It's like up, up, down, down
left, right, left, right
BA, BA, select, start, powers
up your lives and Contra.
You need lives
and cash is that Nintendo
cheat sheet hack.
And so that's what it is.
Cash is oxygen.
Cash, say it with me being on nation.
Super important,
I see this from entrepreneurs
to the biggest companies
in the world.
I'm fascinated that we don't have
more sophisticated conversations,
of separating branding
and marketing and sales.
How many people here follow
me and like my stuff?
Great.
(crowd cheers)
What you guys are feeling is branding.
You're feeling branding.
I'm paying out to build a halo effect
of what Gary Vee means.
It's why you like it
'cause I'm not selling you.
The selling that branding
comes is when my book comes out
in January this year,
you're gonna feel somewhere between guilt
'cause I gave it all away for free,
(audience laughs)
to just passionate and wanna support.
Somewhere between there
which creates a sale.
I know that.
But here is the most important thing
so where everybody fucking breaks down
'cause I see some faces that I know.
And this is where people
break down on my thing.
I give everything away for free,
I hope it creates brand,
and then I have moments
of whether my sneaker
that's coming out on my
birthday in November this year,
or a book in January,
or something else,
I hope,
and think,
and expect,
and would like to think
it converts into sales.
But here's the single
most important thing,
if it doesn't convert,
I am not crippled.
Where people struggle is they give
with expectation of return.
YouTube watcher, what's up It's Gary Vee.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also wanna ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration
of YouTube is about to explode.
Stories, polls, more
content, more engagement,
more surprise and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it
and I hope I see you soon.